be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly so the origins of the guardians
of the universe are given to us in
secret origins number 23 in 1988 now
this origin actually comes out of the
crisis on Infinite Earths event but
because the Green Lantern continuity
never received a reboot with the new 52
this information still remains intact as
the origin of the Guardians themselves
now what we're told in this story is
that the Guardians originated on a
planet called Malthus as the first
living beings to come into existence
with the birth of the universe but as
time progressed on this planet
single-celled organisms eventually gave
way to multi-celled organisms which
resulted in an organism that's really
only referred to as micro colonies
now DC isn't very clear with the basis
behind these organisms or these micro
colonies but what they seem to be
telling us here is that these these
colonies these cells seem to exist as
part of a symbiotic relationship with
various life-forms on the planet and
that they effectively help these animals
evolve and maintain an edge over the
animals that did not possess these cells
and so eventually with the help of these
micro cells with this symbiotic
relationship animals grew into humanoids
which in turn began to establish a kind
of organized society and as the eons
past this society eventually began to
move towards the advancement of science
and technology now ultimately the
Society of Malthusians which they pretty
much referred to were met with a plague
and while most of the race within the
confines of various cities were
effectively killed off those who lived
in isolation those who lived and various
mountains of rural areas were not and so
eventually scientists discovered a sect
of women on mountains that it removed
themselves from a male environment in
the sense that they had basically cast
men aside and what they found was that
these women while they did have this
plague within them the plague was
dormant and so what they basically
discovered here was that if men and
women came into contact with one another
that the plague would become active and
so the only real thing they saw for for
these races to do was to effectively
isolate themselves from one another but
the problem here was at the Malthusian
still had to find a way to propagate
their race and so because they couldn't
use more traditional methods of
procreation what they ended up doing is
they ended up looking towards the idea
of biologic
Engineering their offspring rather than
simply having intercourse or at least
what we were presumed to be some kind of
intercourse between men and women now
the result was that as generations
passed and the method of biological
engineering began to basically become
more and more streamlined the offspring
found themselves on the cusp of
immortality and as a result there was no
real need for offspring anymore in the
sense that if they were immortal there
was no reason to have kids and so what
we found was that somewhere along the
line the genetic line of the of the
Malthusian sea would become the
Guardians
basically stopped and this is the reason
why the Guardians as we see them in DC
Comics are basically immortal and they
don't seem to age here now in addition
what we find is that while other members
of the race of maltruant were very
satisfied with their history that is to
say with the understood origin of the
universe with the progression of their
race in terms of how it was a chronicled
what we found was that there was a man
named corona and chrono is actually not
satisfied with any of this instead
Corona wanted to basically push the
limits of societal standards in the
sense that he wanted to go all the way
back and witness the origin of the
universe for himself
and so what we found was that as a
result of Cronus actions that Corona had
basically done two things the first was
that his actions had resulted in the
splinter of the universe in the sense
that we found the multiverse as well as
the creation of the the antimatter
universe and the formation of the
anti-monitor going into the crisis on
Infinite Earths but the other thing was
that we saw Cronus actions creating the
essence of evil where evil hadn't
existed before and so as a result the I
guess a sect of the male Trojans had
basically retreated away from the planet
Malthus and they had retreated to OA now
this is where the guardians of the
universe basically got their start what
they ended up doing here is realizing
that evil now existed in the universe
and that in some capacity it would take
form they decided to create a kind of a
universal police force and so as we know
given the history of the Red Lanterns
one of the first police forces they
created were the Manhunters but again
tying into the history of the Red
Lanterns the mountain I'm sorry the
Manhunters are basically a total
disaster
they had pretty much lost their minds
their programming had gone awry and as a
result the Guardians as well as various
other races within the universe at this
time really didn't seem to have a choice
but to basically hunt down
Manhunters and try to bring them to an
end and so in response to the Guardians
effectively failed attempts to create
some kind of universal police force in
the form of robots they instead
basically using the power of the central
battery they basically created range
they created the Green Lantern rings and
the goal here was to allow the Rings to
effectively decide who was worthy so
that they wouldn't pick individuals who
would just arbitrarily carry out tasks
that instead they would pick individuals
best suited for the position meaning
that they would be able to be a sound
mind of sound heart they would have a
moral compass they would be able to
determine right from wrong and if the
need was necessary step in and perhaps
even challenge the very essence of what
it was they were being required to do
with that being said we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it and if this
video is well received who because
really seem to like this video though we
may step into the realm of explaining
the origins of the red lanterns and the
Sinestro Corps different things like
that but let me know down in the
comments section if that's something you
guys would like to see what that being
said now we'll catch you guys later
[Music]